عندما يلتقي الاصدقاء فيما بينهم بولايه
ميشيغن هذه الايام يطغى موضوع خيار بايدن
ام لا في الانتخابات الرئاسيه المقبله مع
نهايه العام الله عز وجل ها سنن يقول
الناخبون العرب انهم مصدومون من مواقف
الرئيس بايدن منذ بدايه الحرب على غزه
وغاضب من دعمه بشكل مطلق حسب قولهم
لاسرائيل وعدم التفاته الى ضحايا غزه لهذه
الاسباب يقولون انهم سيعطون صو الانتخابيه
لطرف ثالث بعيدا عن الحزب الديمقراطي حكيت
مع ناس قريبين بمش بهيوستن تكساس حتى
العرب هناك نفس الشيء كلهم واقفين وقفه
وحده انه ضد بايدن للانتخابات
الجايه الشيء الوحيد الذي لا اتفق بشانه
هو اننا نناديه هنا بجول اباده او جول
جزار هل ماذا مستحيل مستحيل انا وا اي
واحد حدي يصوت لبايدن حتى لو رجع لعنا
اليوم وغير رايه ما في له صوت ما في
كان لموقف الرئيس بايدن الداعم لاسرائيل
في حربها على غزه اثر مباشر على الناخبين
العرب والمسلمين بولايه مشيغن فتد نت
شعبيته في اوسطهم هم الذين كانوا ساهموا
بشكل واضح في فوزه بولايه مشيغن عام 2020
عندما واجه المرشح ترامب
انذاك ومنذ بدايه حرب غزه الى يومنا وامام
عدم مطالبه الرئيس بايدن بوقف اطلاق النار
في غزه بشكل صريح حسب الناخبين العرب تضع
غضبهم من البيت الابيض وشاركوا بفعاليه في
المظاهرات الاحتجاجيه بولايه
مشجن استطلاعات رائين للمعهد العربي
الامريكي بواشنطن ذكرت ان شعبيه بايدن
تراجعت بالفعل وبشكل ملحوظ منذ بدايه
الحرب الاسرائيليه على غزه وان غضب
الناخبين العرب دفعهم الان الى القيام
بحملات الكترونيه تدعو صراحه الى التخلي
عن حمله بايدن الانتخابيه والدخول في
تحالفات جديد الجيل الصاعد يعني الفتي
يعني في الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
الناخب الصغير يعني بالعمر اللي هو بين 18
35 هو يعني 62% او 67% حسب الاحصاءات معنا
نحن بده وقف اطلاق النار وهذ توقيف
المجازر لانه نحنا مش بس لوحدنا ننا عندنا
حلفاء في الجاليه السوداء في الجاليه
الاسبانيه مع استمرار الحرب والى اجل
الانتخابات الرئاسيه الامريكيه
اختار الناخبون العرب والمسلمون المشاركه
في عشرات الاحتجاجات الاسبوعيه في
الولايات المتحده الى جانب باقي
الامريكيين للمطالبه بوقف اطلاق النار
ويوم التصويت قد يعاقبون الرئيس بايدن في
صناديق الاقتراع يتفادى البيت الابيض الرد
على الناخبين المسلمين بشكل مباشر ولكن
الرئيس بايدن اكد في تصريحات قبل يومين
انه هو المرشح الذي يحمي حقوق الاقليات
عكس منافسي ترامب الذي يتوعد الان مناصري
حماس كما يقول بالتردي والترحيل نناصر
حسين الجزيره ديربورن
مشجن